Iowa Democrats say they have finally
reported all the results from Monday's
caucus CBS News cannot call a winner the
delegate count shows former mayor Pete
Budaj
and senator Bernie Sanders essentially
tied for first the Democratic National
Committee Chairman wants a recount to
assure voters the results are accurate
and O'Keefe is covering the upcoming New
Hampshire primary and as the recount
likely to happen
well good morning Anthony a recount
would have to be requested by one of the
candidates by this afternoon and as of
now we have no indication that's coming
especially from the two candidates who
are actually winning one of them p-goon
a judge found out last night during a
town hall meeting that he'd prepared
that he'd prevailed by just a tenth of a
percentage point in the delegate count
that's fantastic news
former mayor Pete Buddha judge and
senator Bernie Sanders are claiming
victory in the Iowa caucuses we did very
well we won in Iowa even saying so
before the Iowa Democratic Party
released the final results late Thursday
if that argument is about electability
and the ability to win we just had the
first election of the 2020 process but
what I want to do today three days late
is to thank the people of Iowa why not
let Iowa finish counting first before
declaring victory given the fact that we
have waited three days and now there is
a talk of another recount you know maybe
we might want the decisions of the Iowa
caucus before the November election with
100 percent of precincts now reporting
the results show Buda judge with 26.2
percent of state delegates and Sanders
26.1 but Sanders leads Buda judge in the
popular vote by more than 2600 votes
this was you know a major-league failure
Democratic National Committee Chairman
Tom Perez says there were errors
reported in a number of Iowa precincts
and a recanvass is necessary
I want to make sure that every Iowa
voter knows that their vote was counted
but Sanders and buddha-heads want to
move on and are looking ahead to
Tuesday's primary I think we have an
excellent chance to win here in New
Hampshire recent polling shows Sanders
on
with Buddha Jets closest behind followed
by senator Elizabeth Warren former Vice
President Joe Biden and senator Amy
Klobuchar New Hampshire is a state that
has never been told what to do right and
we've got to earn every vote and earn a
win on Tuesday night right here another
potentially critical turning point comes
tonight when there's a debate here in
Manchester seven of the candidates on
stage together before a full weekend of
campaigning ahead of Tuesday's primary
Anthony all right ed thanks